but Russia has had a long a
long-standing relationship uh with with
India
um we completely understand that of
course what we are hoping is that as
many countries as possible uh speak and
vote in condemnation of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine of course that will
be a conversation that we continue to
have with our Indian friends and
counterparts
um but ultimately of course what we are
also seeking to do is ensure that as as
well as looking for a resolution to
Russia's invasion of Ukraine we are
simultaneously seeking to address these
long-standing Global issues that India
has put on the agenda for this year's uh
g20s